[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
et
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo une vidéo un peu spécial
parce que je vais faire quelque chose
que je n'ai jamais fait c'est répondre
aux questions qu'on me pose sur la
classe inversée alors la chaîne est
encore très modeste 1 je veux pas faire
comme les grands évacuent des
différentes chaînes youtube qui existent
ou tous les suiveurs de la chaîne on
voit des questions et finalement
youtuber y répond non non jour beaucoup
plus simplement ben il ya des questions
qui lui sont posées dans mon entourage
proche
mais aussi parmi certains collègues et
les questions qui sont formulées et ici
l'occasion m'est donnée de répondre à
ces questions au travers d'un travail de
groupe qui est réalisé par un groupe
d'étudiants jeu plus dans quel délai
auquel discipline enfin je le mettrais
dans les commentaires de la vidéo et il
me demande de répondre à différentes
questions parce qu'ils font un travail
sur la classe l'inversé donc il
interroge plusieurs profs qui font ça et
donc une pause 6 questions et je trouve
que ces six questions sont vraiment une
bonne synthèse finalement de tout ce
qu'on peut dire de la classe inversé est
en tout cas moi tout ce que j'ai envie
de dire par rapport à la casse inversée
et donc je vais profiter bas des six
questions qu'il pose à la fois pour leur
répondre donc cette vidéo leur ai
d'abord adressé mais surtout de pouvoir
éclairer bain les différentes long terme
des personnes qui s'interrogent encore
parfois avec beaucoup de méfiance sur la
classe inversée alors la première
question qui me pose c'est pourriez vous
vous présenter en quelques lignes
svp je m'appelle sylvain drame est alors
je suis prof maintenant depuis je crois
que c'est ma quatrième ou cinquième
année j'ai commencé en 2014 donc voilà
ça fait la quatrième année où la
cinquième année fin bref la cinquième
année je pense et avant je travaillais
comme commercial donc ce n'était pas du
tout lié aux disciplines que j'enseigne
maintenant savoir que j'ai une licence
en sciences politiques et sociales puis
bien sûr l'agrégation et
un star mans dans ma carrière ben voila
j'aimerais un peu le tour de la question
je me suis dit tiens je faire
l'agrégation et me voilà donc au cours
pour devenir prof je voulais pas
forcément devenir prof c'était vraiment
pour pour une corde de plus à mon arc
finalement et il se trouve que de fil en
aiguille bas ça m'a beaucoup plu cette
agrégation temps les cours théoriques
les stages sur le terrain et parmi les
cours théoriques bas j'ai eu cours avec
marcel lebrun alors marcel lebrun
peut-être que si vous vous intéressez
déjà à la casse inversée vous le
connaissez c'est un peu le spécialiste
belge de la classe inversée et le court
quand nous avons eu avec marcel lebrun
moi m'a donné vraiment une claque et je
me suis dit si jean sannier un jour
c'est ça que je veux faire
et donc voilà je me suis lancée après
comme enseignant avec beaucoup de
gentillesse mon employeur m'a libérée
assez facilement pour que je puisse
trouver un intérim parce que le début de
carrière c'est toujours un peu difficile
mais dès les premiers intérim
j'ai essayé d'appliquer vraiment ce que
je voulais faire et ce que je voulais
faire c'était utiliser la classe
inversée notamment donc voilà j'espère
que je me suis présentée de manière
suffisamment courtes même temps vous
pouvez essayer de bien cibler finalement
dans quel contexte inscrire ma démarche
alors la deuxième question depuis
combien de temps pratiquez vous la
classe inversée votre dispositif at il
évolué avec le temps je pense que la
première question je viens d'y répondre
alors sur la question du dispositif
évidemment ça a beaucoup évolué au début
on tâtonne donc moi j'ai beaucoup essayé
beaucoup de choses alors j'ai profité
vraiment d un terrible puisque parfois
dans une à deux semaines de remplacement
un mois et je me suis pas dit tiens je
suis là que pour deux semaines on le dit
aux élèves
voilà pour les deux semaines ou un mois
on va déjà travaillé comme ça et je me
suis lancé alors parfois c'était facile
parce qu'il ya des salles informatiques
qui permettait de 10 travailler parfois
les élèves sont plus plus enclins à
accepter les nouveautés finalement que
le prof propose même comme j'arrivais de
toute façon avec ma méthode je crois que
quand on est remplaçant ben on arrive
toujours avec sa méthode et les élèves
basse adapter le rôle en place en
s'adaptant sûr aussi bien sûr aux élèves
qu'il a devant lui mais de toute façon
il ya quand même
bouleversement donc autant l'injecter de
manière drastique à ce moment là autant
vraiment y aller franco avec ce qu'on
veut faire en classe et donc au départ
d'un c'était du tâtonnement alors j'ai
vraiment essayé la classe inverser le
modèle classique selon mme aux drm
marcel lebrun je vous mettre ici en
images un petit peu son modèle et la
classe du premier niveau voilà de la
place inversée de premier niveau si on
peut dire ça comme ça où on a vraiment
le modèle classique les cours
enfin les leçons à la maison les devoirs
à l'école donc finalement la vidéo ou un
texte écrit parce que marcel lebrun le
dit très bien est à s'inverser
c'est pas de nouveau c'est quelque chose
qui se faisait déjà avant quand le prof
disait la tiens lisez ça chez vous et
puis après les élèves revenaient en
classe avec le texte en tête et ont
travaillé sur ce texte ou sur la théorie
qui avait été vu à la maison donc la
vidéo permet de voir la théorie à la
maison et la théorie est appliquée en
classe ou est utilisé en classe ça c'est
vraiment le modèle classique basique on
pourrait penser qu'on fait ça tous les
cours se font comme ça mais c'est tout à
fait faux parce que le modèle évolue
très vite
en fait on va utiliser le la capacité
qu'a la classe inversée à exporter la
théorie en dehors des murs de la classe
pour pouvoir mettre les élèves en
activité dans la classe donc c'est
vraiment ça ça ça l'important et les
élèves vont être de plus en plus actifs
à tel point que c'est parfois même eux
qui vont aller chercher la théorie angle
à s'inverser donc à la maison il cherche
des ressources il les postes par exemple
sur un groupe et en classe on utilise
tout ça donc là on a vraiment le modèle
traditionnel de la classe qui est
complètement explosé et la temporalité
aussi parce qu'en fait on travaille en
classe en vue de réaliser une production
finale et comment est ce qu'on fait
cette production on injecte de la
théorie ça peut être le prof qui injecte
la théorie mais c'est des élèves qui
vont chercher aussi des ressources
théorique ou simplement du matériel pour
pour analyser par exemple donc ça c'est
vraiment la place inversée deuxième
niveau où le prochain
deux postures et où les savoirs
finalement ne sont plus donnés par le
prof mais simplement je puis dire validé
par le prof
puisque ce sont les élèves eux mêmes qui
vont chercher la théorie ou les
ressources donc voilà donc ça a bien
évolué mais maintenant j'arrive quand
même un certain stade de maturité je
pense dans le dispositif est donc là ça
va plus trop évolué mais ça reste
toujours très très mouvant quoi parce
que l'idée c'est justement de s'adapter
aux élèves mais aussi que les élèves
construisent entre eux avec le prof
et donc c'est des pros ce processus qui
sont au fond fièrement évolutif
voilà je pense avoir bien répondu à
cette deuxième question
attention n'hésitez pas il ya les
commentaires ainsi je réponds pas
suffisamment ou si c'est pas clair mon
profond je suis un peu dans je m'en
porte un petit peu dans tout ce que je
dois dire donc n'hésitez pas à poser
d'autres questions dans les commentaires
on y répondra par une nouvelle vidéo où
je répondrai directement par écrit
alors quelle a été votre principale
motivation à changer de méthode
d'enseignement
ben j'ai pas changé puisque je vous dis
je les fais directement comme ça mais ma
motivation c'était vraiment que on
arrête avec cette image moi j'avais
l'image est gelée toujours quand je fais
des cathédrales parce qu'il faut pas
croire que fait pas d'exploiter drain le
prof qui parle tout le temps ça arrive
toujours pas ce qu'est la théorie qu'on
sait pas faire en vidéo il ya des choses
il fallait recommencer donc voilà donc
parfois il faut s'adapter aussi et le
transmissif excédera peut être très
utile parfois on fait d'extraits
t'aidera et on voit les élèves mais qui
sont complètement déconnecté de ce qu'on
leur dit quoi
donc ils sont là cinquante minutes on
sait déjà que après vingt minutes on
décroche alors nous mêmes adultes
quand nous allons nous-mêmes adultes
enseignants quand nous allons à des
formations darfour d'intelligent qui
décroche après après 20 minutes et nous
on aux élèves de faire ça 8 heures 8
heures par jour mais c'est complètement
utopique comme comme comme système
finalement et donc moi j'avais plus
envie j'avais pas envie j'ai vraiment
pas envie que je te laisse atteindra
parfois il faut que je me m'oblige parce
que
finalement les je vois plus trop
l'intérêt mais parfois c'est nécessaire
comme je le dis et donc on voit les
élèves qui décrochent les uns après les
autres et même des bons élèves qui ont
envie mais qui décrochent parce qu'ils
n'y arrivent plus il expose concentrer
sur ce à quoi l'on pourrait se dire oui
mais c'est parce qu'ils ont les
smartphones ils ont ils savent plus
concentré mais c'est pareil avec nous
c'est pas avec nous quand j'étais à
l'agrégation je voyais des copains et
tout ça elle même moi même qui après dix
minutes décrocher complètement du court
parce que voilà on était fatigués parce
qu'il y avait il y avait des choses qui
se passaient on avait chevaux navettes
fin que ce n'était pas intéressant pour
vos mails et des raisons évidemment
donc moi j'ai voulu changer de modèle
j'ai pas voulu changer parce que j'ai
toujours fait comme ça mais en tout cas
si j'ai appliqué ce modèle là c'était
pour éviter vraiment ça et que les
élèves apprennent qu'ils apprennent
enfin en classe
la quatrième question toutes vos leçons
sont elles données en classe inversée
j'ai répondu mais c'est une question
finalement qui sans trop d'objets parce
que voilà on va pas avoir un modèle où
il ya une vidéo pour le mardi le
mercredi on fait les devoirs en classe
le jeudi une nouvelle vidéo le vendredi
on fait les devoirs en classe c'est pas
du tout ça la classe inversé c'est
vraiment ou créer sa séquence de courant
comme j'ai envie de dire comme ingénieur
pédagogique finalement on essaie de
trouver différents entre sourds
différents outils et dentelle comme ça
qui se créent et la casse inversée en
tout cas la vidéo telle qu'on la voit où
la place un texte à lire à la maison
mais ça va venir un certain moment donc
voilà mais tout le chaque modèle
chaque fois que je fais une séquence de
coups une nouvelle séquence de cours il
ya toujours de la classe inversée dedans
ça c'est sûr et de la casse inversée de
niveau 2 1 celle où on demande aux
élèves aussi d'aller toucher des
ressources ça c'est pas toujours
possible de l'intégrer mais j'essaie de
plus en plus et j'y arrive de plus en
plus à intégrer ça dans mes deux
séquences de court en fait alors la
cinquième question quels sont vos
critères pour juger de la pertinence de
donner ses cours en classe inversée y a
pas de critères puisque le critère c'est
l'onf et de la classe inversée utilisé
dans dans la boîte aux outils finalement
pour construire une séquence de cours
mais généralement de la théorie pure
sécession cas s'inverser si c'est pour
je raconte ma vie
20minutes fin je livre ma vie la théorie
je veux dire si c'est pour raconter la
théorie pendant 22 30 50 minutes je vois
pas l'intérêt de faire ça devant les
élèves on perd 50 minutes alors ça
m'arrive de le faire parce que j'aime
bien aussi qu'ils aient une variété dans
les dispositifs qu'ils ont devant eux et
que parfois il est quand même de la
théorie qui soient donnés comme ça pour
les habitués aussi à la prise de notes
et tout ça mais ça reste ponctuel
ça reste avec 2 ticks l'idée c'est
vraiment de la théorie ça sert à rien de
passer son temps en classe là dessus
puisque je le ferais mieux en vidéo je
pourrais couper la vidéo je pourrais
ajouter des documents dans la vidéo je
pourrais mettre des liens dans la vidéo
les élèves pour retourner voir cette
vidéo les élèves pourront regarder
plusieurs fois cette vidéo
les élèves pourront faire un arrêt
pendant la vidéo pour notre prendre des
notes
donc je trouve que la théorie ça se
donne beaucoup mieux en vidéo voilà
certaines disciplines histoire géo s'y
prête elle plus que d'autres je pense
pas franchement je pense pas j'ai même
une collègue se reconnaîtra s'il regarde
la vidéo qui avait même préparé des
classes inversée pour éducation physique
donc elle n'était pas prof d'éducation
physique mais dans son école elle
voulait mettre en place un petit peu la
classe à verser ce qui lui avait été
demandé en tout cas par la direction est
elle même proposé des capsules de classe
inversée en éducation physique mais
quand je me suis comment quand j'ai
commencé à me documenter sur la classe
inversée j'ai vu des profs de maths qui
vous attaquent à s'inverser j'ai vu des
profs de physique qui faisait la classe
inversée moi je suis plutôt en sciences
humaines
ben je trouve que ça ça aussi sur
l'utilité peut-être pas pour les mêmes
choses un chacun et chaque discipline
doit trouver finalement lusage affaire
qu'elle doit faire de la casse versée
mais je pense qu elle vraiment aucune
exclusive là dessus maintenant la vidéo
par exemple pour le cours de géographie
c'est super pratique parce qu'on peut
vraiment montrer les différentes zones
on peut vraiment travaillé sur sur du
visuel sur de l'espace en sciences
sociales il ya moins de visuels mais le
lac à s'inverser à apporte aussi une
plus value au niveau théorique parce que
parfois on est sur des concepts un peu
denses
on peut donner beaucoup d'exemples plus
que par exemple en classe donc je trouve
que franchement il n'ya pas de
d'exclusivité par rapport à une
discipline
franchement la sixième question est la
suivante suite à vos années d'expérience
quels sont selon vous les principaux
avantages ainsi que les principales
limites rencontrées alors les avantages
comme je lé 10 et de re motiver les
élèves alors on les motive pas parce
qu'on utilise la vidéo c'est de la
technologie ils vont être motivés ou
l'ordinateur à la technologie ils vont
être motivés deux mois avec la
technologie mais après ça va devenir de
l'habitude donc c'est pas la technologie
qui les motive ce qui les motive c'est
le dispositif de coûts dans lequel ils
deviennent acteurs donc ils sont acteurs
avec une marge de liberté avec beaucoup
d'autonomie qui leur est donnée et et ça
ça ça marche
moi ça m'arrive de mettre les élèves
dehors du coup un leur diamano bon
maintenant c'est tout vous arrêter de
travailler sur vos productions sur votre
apport ou sur votre caste c'est tout le
corps est fini maintenant il faut passer
à l'autre court ou parfois 16h40 donc
nous on sonne l'école se termine à 16
heures car à 16h20 il ya encore des
élèves qui sont là j'ai pas que c'est à
chaque fois que c'est plutôt là pour
tous les élèves
pourtant faire dire ce que je n'ai pas
dit mais il ya des voix là c'est la
motivation extrême et j'ai plus besoin
de les mettre au travail de verdir allez
tu dois travailler globalement ils se
mettent tous au travail parce qu'il ya
un objectif c'est la production et les
productions sont valorisés aussi peuvent
être valorisés aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux sur les différentes manières
donc il ya un enjeu quelque part si vous
voulez cette production elle représente
à un enjeu et il aime beaucoup faire ça
et de le faire eux-mêmes de le faire
eux-mêmes mais c'est pareil pour nous
mêmes je ne sais pas on n'a pas appris à
conduire en lisant le code de la route
on a appris le code de la route
finalement en étant sur le terrain et
conduire la voiture en étant sur le
terrain c'est pas en lisant donc les
modes d'emploi que la voiture qu'on sait
l'utiliser ici j'ai une nouvelle
nouvelle caméra que j'utilise ici puis
deux
vidéo j'ai pas appris à l'utiliser en
lisant le manuel ça m'a un peu aidé mais
c'est ma succès surtout maintenant que
je la teste
il rassemble encore des petits problèmes
de mise au point des choses comme ça qui
vont arriver une lumière mais voilà
c'est en faisant les choses qu'on les
apprend le forgeron il n'apprend pas à
forger en lisant la forge rené pour les
nuls là où la forge pour les nuls
non il apprend en forgeant alors
évidemment encore une fois ne faites pas
dire ce que je n'ai pas dit il faut pas
qu'il faut pas exclure toute théorie la
théorie vient mais pour nourrir cet
apprentissage qui se faisait en étant
actif en étant en activité en faisant
majeur à fillon de gens des sciences
sociales en faisant des mathématiques et
on va on va intégrer toute cette
théorique est si importante
mais justement elle est importante alors
nous ne la gale vos dons pas comme ça
dans découvre excepté drass et moi c'est
mon sens mettons en pratique c'est donc
ça c'est le principe au le principal
avantage c'est de me motiver les élèves
maintenant les inconvénients les limites
se bat c'est ce sont tous les obstacles
que que les élèves que les parents que
les que les directions
voilà chez moi parce que moi j'ai
franchement une direction là dessus qui
est super ouverte et kiki vraiment
encourage les initiatives quand elles
sont quand elles sont judicieuses un don
si on fait des bêtises évidemment
direction est là pour dire aussi
attention là vous êtes peut-être le
mauvais chemin
mais ces voix là c'est des résistances
aux changements qu'on peut qu'on peut
rencontrer les élèves qui veulent pas
alors c'est surtout les bons élèves ceux
qui marchent bien dans le système
traditionnel
ils veulent pas changer ce système
puisque il dit à yves bien alors
pourquoi aller faire des vidéos pourquoi
chercher soi-même
bon après ça ça ne dure qu'un temps
parce que si on est motivé on arrive à
montrer tous les avantages et
comprennent vite l'avantagent que ça je
pense que le taux d'adhésion à la casse
inversée augmentent très très vite mais
au départ il ya une résistance une
réticence au changement enfin une
résistance une réticence qui est une
résistance au changement chez les
collègues aussi mais après on voit que
ça marche et ils voient les avantages
moi je pense aussi que la casse inverser
ça doit pas être un modèle qui
s'appliquer à tout le monde dans tous
les cours de la même manière chacun doit
intégrer la chose de manière subtile et
nuancée pour que ça marche par rapport
déjà son caractère lorsque tous les
profs non plus ne peuvent pas faire des
vidéos
il ya des élèves sans doute que les
vidéos ça ne marchera jamais parce que
voilà ils ont besoin vraiment de l'écrit
mais attendez moi jamais évacuée l'écrit
un souvent les vidéos elles sont en
parallèle avec un syllabus notamment
c'est le cas dans un cours de géographie
un pour chaque vidéo il ya le syllabus
qui est à côté donc il ya l'image et
l'écrit en multiplie les possibilités de
toucher les élèves c'est un autre
avantage maintenant l'inconvénient c'est
qu'on est d'accord que c'est des modèles
qui demandent de l'investissement de la
part de l'élève un l'élève qui veut
juste ouvrir son cours et étudié en
vitesse pour l'intérêt du nom d'un bas
ici avec la classe inversée avec tout ça
tous ces dispositifs de pédagogie actifs
qu'ils utilisent à traverser ben ça
devient plus compliqué il doit il doit y
mettre du sien
donc on fait travailler les élèves qui
d'habitude calcul un petit peu vont
vraiment à l'économie je pense que le
système leur permet d'être plus actif et
de les mettre plus au travail aussi donc
ça c'est un autre avantage donc les
avantages on entend des inconvénients
les inconvénients sont en même temps des
désavantages envie de dire alors
peut-être un gros inconvénient pour le
prof c'est super chronophage faut pas
croire quand dans des classes à verser
on va gagner du temps ou des choses
comme ça bon alors vous allez dire oui
mais c'est parce que vous vous faites ou
toi tu fais tu fais tes vidéos toi même
tu t'investis beaucoup dans les vidéos
ça c'est vrai et je veux dire que la
chaîne youtube finalement ça devient un
petit peu une vie un peu autonome par
rapport aux classes inversée j'utilise
toujours des vidéos en classe mais je
suis aussi des vidéos voilà parce que
j'ai envie de les faire mais maintenant
je dois vous dire que même si vous
récupérez des vidéos de quelqu'un
d'autre bon je pense par exemple au jeu
de la fimo je me suis beaucoup inspiré
au début j'ai beaucoup travaillé que les
vidéos nicolas souligné mais vous devez
quand même les visionner ces vidéos
knoxy à 10 minutes
vidéo s'implique de vidéo mais vous vous
devez vous coltiner les 5-10 minutes de
vidéo je dis ça imaginez que vous ayez
cinq cours à préparer
moi je crois que j'ai si cette cour a
préparé sur la semaine
déjà qu'avec cinq cours à préparer bas
si vous avez 10 minutes à regarder pour
chacun des cours ça vous fait cinquante
minutes de vidéos regardées le soir bon
donc déjà ne fusse qu'utiliser des
vidéos si vous voulez être au courant de
ce qu'il ya dans les vidéos vous n'avez
pas faites vous même il faut les
regarder
bon si vous le faites vous même ça vous
prendra du temps dans une vidéo pour
qu'elles soient bien faites maison ça de
manière relativement minime en terre
pour que ça prenne pas trop de temps il
faut compter 12 heures 2h 2h30 sa
dépense on dit ça pour un jeu tel que
j'ai jamais calculé bon moi quand je
fais des vidéos évidemment j'ai essayé
de mettre des beaucoup de l'image que
j'ai fait moi-même donc ça me prend ça
me prend en fait plus plusieurs jours
mais je pense que ce à quoi donc je fais
plusieurs vidéos il ya plusieurs vidéos
en cours plusieurs projets en cours et
ils sont tous construits au fur et à
mesure bon parfois c'est même en donnant
cours en classe je me dis mais tiens
pourquoi ce que j'ai pas fait une vidéo
avec ça on aurait pu faire une vidéo
avec ça ici notamment
il ya eu beaucoup d'absents au dernier
cours je me suis dit mais tient jusqu'à
une vidéo est le dernier cours comme ça
le tous les absents pourront se remettre
à niveau
donc voila mais ça ça me prend du temps
évidemment alors il faut pas croire
quand vous demandez aussi aux élèves de
chercher de la théorie ça vous prend
aussi donc non tissé les élèves qui vont
chercher eux mêmes les vidéos vous dire
quand même regarder les vidéos ou les
documents qui vous propose donc c'est
très très chronophage voilà je pense que
j'étais assez complet sur toutes les
questions qu'ils avaient été posées s'il
ya encore des escales des
éclaircissements à donner n'hésitez pas
moi ça me plaît beaucoup de parler de
tout ça parce que ça permet aussi
d'avoir des idées et de faire le point
sur sa propre pratique donc n'hésitez
pas je n'imposerai plaisir
il ya plein de vidéos sur la société cas
j'essaie aussi de faire une chaîne par
chaîne
une playlist qui est plus consacré à la
pédagogie et à l'école 2.0 donc là il ya
tout des vidéos évidemment
qui sont plus axées sur sur une
réflexion comme ça pédagogique comme
celle qu'on vient d'avoir maintenant je
vous remercie et après bientôt nous tous
[Musique]